an entire season of work has come down
to one last play it's Super Bowl 50 Phil
they've trained all their lives to be in
this position it's going to live up to
everything you ever dream about it being
get on the return
good kick returned and now the offense
will try to take advantage what a
magnificent leader this offense has
running the show
- Olson touchdown
Wow
they are starting to dominate this
offense
the Panthers look to increase their lead
now as they get the football back
Newton's got the talent to peruse but
the leadership he has it all get up and
there is Peyton Manning ready to get
this next drive underway
never too late that's a touchdown
Paul Miller gets to the quarterback to
leave stepping up and make it another
big play now they've been able to
recover here and they're right back
within sniffing distance of the lead
Denver in for the score Nanjing all
they're thinking about is the job they
got to do to be a Super Bowl champion
let's go
an entire season of work and it looks
like Super Bowl 50 will come down to
this play
touchdown touchdown huge
the Carolina Panthers have won the Super
Bowl
Lombardi Trophy is hitting the Charlotte
North Carolina